It always looks like a disaster.
We've done this, oh, my God.
Our clients say that
we're not going to make it,
we have to fire someone and everything.
If you look at it in the test of,
like a long period of time,
everything works out.
Yoav Vilner,
thank you so much for being on my show,
20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Great. Thanks for inviting me.
Of course.
I have to say that
it's a beautiful balcony
that you have over there in Tel Aviv.
But I do have to start with actually
with your fun fact,
which is the fact
that you play the ukulele.
And you showed it to me
just a second ago behind you there.
We started with that fun fact.
Now, I know how to play
What A Wonderful World.
I taught myself that.
It took me about three years to learn it.
So, I have a lot of respect
to the fact that you claim
that you play the ukulele.
But I want to spend these 20 minutes
talking about you and your journey.
As we get to the climax
of the conversation,
your most recent company, Walnut.
I'd love to go back in time
in to your 20s.
Sales, marketing, leadership,
starting your own businesses,
New York City, Tel Aviv,
walk me through your journey.
Because I think there's a lot to,
a lot of lessons to be learned
about your entrepreneurial journey.
Right.
So, I started my career by accident
when I was 22.
I wanted to do freelance marketing
for startups.
And, you know, 10 years ago,
the startup nation
was a little bit smaller,
so there was room to do that
and be the first one.
So, I did that and it turned out to be
the biggest company in Israel to do that.
We had like 500 clients,
dozens of employees and offices
in Manhattan and London.
So, I had to live in London and Manhattan
like periodically.
And it was a lot of fun.
And after seven years of being the CEO,
I decided I needed to do something more,
something different,
like have more fun.
Yoav, your skipping over
all over the juicy parts.
You're 22 years old,
how do you get to run a company
that has over 500 clients,
with offices in three continents?
I don't understand that.
You know, I always try to think
of a good word to say.
I was a very shitty CEO to start with.
I had employees that were double my age
and they had kids of their own.
And I've made every mistake possible.
But you just want to,
what our life in Israel,
the university of life
you have to go through it
much more than anybody.
And it's worked out.
So, going back,
what were some
of the most monumental moments
or your aha moments
as you were going through this company,
and you're managing the company
first for seven years,
what were some of the most
incredible milestones
that you'll forever keep with you?
I think the first one is
quit your job.
Because I had a very good job
when I was like 21, 22
when I came back from my after army trip,
which was a year long
in Central America.
And I had a really good job.
Like my friends were like,
"How the hell did you get the job,
while we're trying to figure out
where we're going to study
for the next four years?"
But I just quit it
because I wanted to be
like be my own boss.
So, that was probably
the smartest move I've ever made.
And it changed my life.
Yeah.
And the other thing is,
don't worry about being
a very bad founder and CEO
when you're in early 20s,
that's when you have
to make all the mistakes.
But when you get a little bit better,
and older and better and older,
then you're going to be amazing
and have much better background.
And people who have done
an amazing degree
and they were VPs
at some enterprise companies,
you're probably going to beat them
for being the founder.
So, from your experience,
what are some of the most
important things one can do
as a young entrepreneur,
first time entrepreneur,
and in owning those mistakes?
And obviously,
we're all going to make mistakes.
And I'm looking forward
to making many more mistakes
than I'm already making as I go through
my entrepreneurial journey.
But what do we need to do
in order to keep that in mind
and to own them and to fix them?
You need to start by doing them.
And then,
you know, building a startup,
it's like every day
it's the worst mistake than before
in every phase of the startup.
So, I have to do it.
And if you don't do it,
it's like in the gym,
If it doesn't hurt,
then you're not improving.
So, that's the only way.
You need to find yourself
people that you look up to,
and you can give them a call,
give them a WhatsApp message,
annoy them and ask them for,
usually people
that are just a bit  older from you,
they have like
an experience running a company
a little bit better than you.
Surround yourself with those people.
And eventually,
everything always looks like a disaster.
We've done this. Oh my God.
Our clients say that
we're not going to make it,
we have to fire someone,
and everything.
If you look at it,
in the test of a long period of time,
everything works out.
You just got to be
a little bit less emotional.
Right.
Okay. So, then let's continue
in your journey.
You're seven years in,
and you have hundreds of clients,
what are some of the most
important insights you learned
about marketing and PR
through that experience?
Now you're taking a topic
that can be 10 hours,
and you're asking that one question.
That's what's so smart about this show,
because I get to now skip
nine hours of studying
for that one sentence
that everybody's looking for.
Now, of course,
there's no magical answer.
No, I have a lot.
I would say that,
I was also like an adviser
to most of the different accelerators
that you probably know.
And I think,
what I usually told the founders
in terms of early stage marketing
is that you've got to try
and be your own [--].
So, if you're the CEO of the startup
and you start building
your own reputation,
like you create guest articles
on the big publications.
At some point of time of my life
I was writing for,
like 10 US publications.
Really?
Yeah. Like CNBC, Forbes, Fox news.
So, you might not be able
to do all of that,
but you can definitely work
on a couple of channels
that will brand you
as like the founder of that company.
And then,
when you need to raise your announcement,
like raise seed and all that,
you're going to be
already closed to the media.
So you're not gonna need about agencies.
That's actually
a really, really good tip.
I'm going to keep that in mind.
And I think it's you know,
I keep following
the writing that you get and you do,
but also the people that are writing in.
And it always makes me [--]
that I really want to get into that,
because it's not just about
getting your name on those publications,
but it forces you to think critically
about some topics
and to put that thinking into words
that can be meaningful for others.
So, I think that it's
definitely something
that I'm looking forward to.
So, you're writing these publications,
You have that agency
with hundreds of clients,
and what's next on your journey,
on the way to becoming
the CEO of Walnut?
So, you know, I was in New York
for like almost a year
and I just realized that
a marketing company is nice,
but if you don't have 200 employees
and your own building,
that American audience and companies
don't really give a shit.
So, I had to start really encourage me
to start thinking about my next moves.
So, I came back to Israel
and I took some time off.
It was a very long seven years.
I took some time off.
And then we formed the startup
that was designed to save kids
from pedophiles on social media.
Right.
So, it was me
and three more founding members,
[--]
the people probably know.
And after another year of doing that,
which is a great cause
and I hope they succeed.
Just I felt that it's a perfect time for,
then corona started,
people started switching their mindset.
And I just realized,
that was the perfect time for me
to start my own thing again.
And I'm the founder, co-founder, CEO,
and that was the beginning of Walnut.
So, I want to hold on,
on this junction.
Because now you're at a point in time
where you've had an agency,
you have had a very successful business
you grew with your bare hands
in three continents
with dozens of employees and offices.
You've seen what that journey is like
and what selling
and getting to a good product is like.
Then you're part of the founding team
of a company
that is growing very, very quickly,
raised a lot of money
with a very well-known
and respected CEO with a great cause,
and you're deciding to go back
to the drawing board
and to create a company from scratch,
Walnut.
Was it that you just had
to create something of your own,
like have your own baby?
Was it that you wanted
to really see
what it's like to be that CEO
of a hypergrowth startup?
What was it that really attracted you?
That's an amazing question.
I think it was a combination of,
I think everyone's life
has changed a little bit,
like seven months ago
or eight months ago.
And for me I felt the change,
the main thoughts that I had
while we were quarantined during March,
were that I have to do
my own thing again.
I have to name it.
I have to decide what the product
is going to do.
And it just felt right.
And I don't really know
how to explain it.
It just felt right.
I just do it like before,
which I've done always.
So, I decided that I'm going to pursue
what I'm feeling.
And everything, kind of like
all of the stars aligned ever since.
It was really starting off
with the right foot.
I have to say that
I'm drawing a parallel
to a lot of the other interviews
that I've had on the show.
Almost every guest
comes with a non-linear career path.
And almost always,
the recurring theme is that
they had this gut feeling
like the one you're describing that says,
Michael, I can't really explain it
in words.
I had to do it.
That it was you know,
they said that entrepreneurs are crazy.
And I think that's part of the insanity.
Right?
Feeling like you have to go
with your heart.
It's a bug.
Walnut. What's walnut?
Right.
So, I left my previous startup.
And Danni, my co-founder,
who is a brilliant technology guy,
he sold like two startups
and then he oversaw
like 70 something developers
that we work.
He kind of was looking for,
we were just kind of imploded.
And he was looking also
to start his next thing.
And we started,
it wasn't a matter of ideation,
which is the process that I hate the most
when you start a new company,
because it's a never ending process.
There's no idea that
[--] every day, all day.
We were both kind of excited
about this whole thing of revolutionizing
how companies present themselves
to other companies.
And we just started building
and [--], and interviewed
60 enterprise companies
and saw what they would
probably pay for if we build.
And everything just started off
like a serious roller coaster since.
So, you mentioned very briefly
the industry of
showing your product to others
or demoing your product.
And when we had a really nice walk
on Ben-Gurion Street,
you really explained to me
the pain point behind a team's ability
to present their product
to another team, live.
So, talk to me a little bit
about the space
and why is Walnut so relevant in 2020?
So, 2020 is the year
where everything's done remote, so.
And during the regular times,
let's say, of the previous year,
before corona,
companies always have
like a lot of friction
between the sales team and the back end.
So, the sales team
has to ask the designer
to design something,
not to touch the back end
so it doesn't break.
Add a feature into it.
And, you know,
it's like a cross-cultural problem.
I think companies has that problem.
It doesn't matter who you are,
It doesn't matter what's the size.
So, we started building like an editor,
like you would edit a website on WIX,
and it's on our cloud.
So, you edit the sales demo
and it's unbreakable
because it's on a CDM.
And we just started building it.
We showed it to a lot of companies,
everyone wanted to hire us.
And then we raised seed
this takes like a month,
and went from some of the investors
that I consider to be the best around.
And now, we're growing the team,
onboarding clients.
And that's amazing.
So, give me a little bit more insight
into this product
and the actual experience.
So, you mentioned that
one of the interesting solutions
that you've discovered here is that
you can actually
disintegrate the sales team
from the product and back-end team,
such that the sales team
can write their own demos
without having to interface
with the back-end team
and without blocking each other.
So, is this like, you know,
just like a demo where you recorded
and then you show it?
Or is it a live demo
where you can play around with it?
Because obviously,
you want to play around with the demo
live in front of clients.
So, it's not a video
and it's not a screenshot
and it's not a mock up.
It's an actual, touchable,
it's a product that the sales people
had to dive in like
two minutes before the call
and customize.
If we personalize everything,
the only reason that Netflix
beat all the big movie producers
and Hollywood directors is that
because it gives us
a lot of customization.
And we build our [--],
and it's all very reachable.
So, that's a big difference.
When you're selling a product,
it has to be customized
to the client you're showing it to.
And we just gave them that tool.
And we realized
that there is too much of a demand
than we can handle.
Because we launched and we got like,
almost a thousand companies
to reach out in like a month.
And yeah.
And pretty much,
the most amazing companies
that you can imagine,
I don't want to name them,
but pretty much the biggest
enterprise companies in the world.
Sometimes it was two different teams
from the same company reaching out,
not minding
the others have reached out.
So, we've proven that there's a problem.
And all of this in how long
since the inception?
Seven months, maybe.
Seven months.
That's unbelievable.
So,
walk me through
the first seven months of, you know,
a fast growing startup,
you're the CEO,
what's bothering you?
Like, what makes you tick
before you go to sleep?
My phone.
You know, it's like a never ending,
it's a never ending ordeal.
Yoav, you seem too calm.
You're too relaxed.
Like, I'm nervous for you.
You're growing so fast,
you're onboarding more employees,
you have a thousand companies
waiting in line,
and you're sitting there relaxed
and saying, yes, I'm enjoying it.
Yeah, I had something to drink
before we got on this topic.
I learned that for the next one.
No, if you're pressured,
and if you're relax,
you're going to reach pretty much
the same problem.
So, I have no choice.
But during the day,
like nights like 9PM at night,
during the day,
we're working in a rollercoaster,
like everyone's working their ass off.
And, you know, at nights
we talk to the American companies,
investors and everyone.
Right.
Yeah. You know, it's a lot of fun.
I think it's the most fun I've had
in all of my career, honestly.
It's so fun and inspiring for me
to be talking to somebody
who's already had a marvelous career
and has impacted
on so many organizations.
And now you're saying that,
that literally now
is the most fun you're having.
That just makes me want to go
and start my own thing already.
What surprised you
over these seven months?
What caught you off guard
that you're like, oh, wow,
I didn't realize this before?
I was afraid
because it was like a crisis
and people were holding on to their jobs.
I was afraid
that it's going to be hard for us
to recruit the talent.
And now it's easier
because we had PR about us
and we raised money.
But before we actually raised the money,
I was really surprised
at how people were loyal
to working
or joining our team
like our founding team,
even before
there was the first investor in,
even before the first client was in.
And we're very grateful to them.
Some of the best people I know,
they have like 10, 15 years
down the road in the industry.
And I'm really proud
of the team that we've built.
Now, it's going to be harder
because when you've done working
with your first circle
of friends of friends,
you're starting to grow and be,
you know, 10, 15, 20, 30,
and you've got to hire
people you don't know,
your friends don't know,
your colleagues don't know,
and it's getting to be more skeptical
But also, it happened to me too
like two times already before.
So, I hope it'll be fine again.
Right.
And Yoav, usually at this point
of the conversation,
I ask, what is some advice you would give
to a young entrepreneur like myself
as I am gearing up
towards starting my own.
But what I'm taking away
from this conversation is both, you know,
quit your job, especially if it means
following your heart
and if you're doing something,
because sometimes, not always,
but sometimes the end result
is you're able to say
that you're having the most fun
you ever had in your life
or in your career.
And obviously,
anybody who's looking at the stats
of what you've been doing
the past seven months can see
what an incredible journey
this has been for you.
Especially during a crisis that,
that basically immobilized
most of the startups in the world.
So, I think that's pretty exciting.
Yoav, before we go, though,
I have to ask for three words
that you would use to describe yourself,
or three words that your co-founder
or one of your team members
would use to describe you.
Should have done my homework
and prepare some.
No, no, spontaneous is the key.
Three words,
I
would say emotional.
I didn't expect that.
Not in my personal life,
but when building a startup,
I'm very emotional
which is not good.
I think my team members
would use a name to describe me,
that's someone that's
making it complicated to order lunch.
Undeciding.
And also a little bit being late
to places all the time.
But besides that,
I think I'm a really decent guy.
Yoav, you definitely are.
And I very much appreciate
our friendship,
and I learn a lot from you.
So, thank you for both
giving the time to do this show
and for teaching me
throughout the journey.
And it's been a lot of fun
following you,
and I can't wait to follow Walnut
and the things you're doing.
And other than that,
I just have to wish you
to stay safe and stay healthy.
Likewise.
And then good luck with your book.
Everyone going to buy it.
That's awesome.
Thank you, Yoav.
Take care.
Bye bye.